it's time to talk about the draft annual
plan for 2023 this budget marks the
final year of council's long-term plan
since Council adopted the ltp in 2021
the waimakuru district like the rest of
New Zealand and the world has faced many
challenges
these include the effects of covid-19
supply chain issues Rising energy costs
and inflationary pressures
simply there has been no economic period
quite like this in the last 30 years
Council had projected a rise in rates of
4.3 percent for this year but this
inflation increased it put significant
pressure on our budgets
continue to provide the level of service
our residents deserve has been a greater
rates increase than expected Council
started with a proposed rate increase of
14.4 percent to meet inflationary
pressures
we reviewed our program extensively and
managed to cap our rates an average of
5.97
significantly lower than the inflation
rate of 7.2 percent
as a result our Council will have one of
the lower increases in New Zealand
importantly it also ensures that any
critical work isn't put off for too long
key issues in the plan include bringing
forward plan upgrades to our drinking
water infrastructure
we also need to make immediate
improvements to the stormwater Network
following flooding from extreme weather
events
our riding budgets have also been
affected by inflation and kept subsidies
from Waka katahi this means more is
needed to make sure local roads remain
at a high standard
and local government there continues to
be a lot of uncertainty with multiple
Central government-driven reform
programs
three Waters Resource Management reforms
the future for local government as well
as modernizing the Emergency Management
framework
there's also new legislation aimed at
climate change and new urban planning
rules which council is required to
follow
I encourage you to read through our plan
for the year share your thoughts and get
involved
everything we do is for the community
and we want to hear from you
talk soon
[Music]